let me first put my title on this this
talk sort of evolved while and mostly
prompted by Eugene Maia who was part of
the CMU activity but that never have him
and then the same sort of theme here
what are we doing at NASA and a search
for life that's relevant to information
science and so I'm really mostly asking
for help in some sense rather than
giving you answers and I'll explain why
I think it's useful to think of the
origin of life and the search for a
second genesis of life on other worlds
in the context of problem as a problem
in information science and to basically
jump to the answer i think the the
hardest thing to understand about life
is not what it's made out of which is
what we've classically focused on but
how it processes information and how did
that arise that's the hardest thing in
the origin of life and i also think
that's the key to recognizing life on
another world is not recognizing some
substance for recognizing the fact that
information processing is been going on
so that's that's what i'm trying to put
some thoughts on together and this is
where we are and this is the date and
this is me and this is where I'm from
that's all pretty straightforward
so the first part of this is how did
life get started and in some sense it
reminds me in a kind of whimsical way of
mathematical problem of NP problems
which you're easy to show that you have
the answer but it's very hard to get the
answer from first principles very hard
to solve but very easy to verify if you
have a solution you can check trivially
that it's the solution but getting the
solution is actually a very very
exponentially hard we have a solution we
know that there is a solution in the
problem of life in fact if we didn't
have it here I would conclude it was
impossible right but we have it here so
there it must
there must be a solution proof by one
example yeah yeah yeah exactly as far as
we can tell yeah and we care so so but
it's very hard to solve so this is a
good starting point that's Mars billions
of years ago that's why it's smaller
gods smaller and the organ of life is
smaller it happened faster so what do we
know about the origin of life well if we
go to the literature there's lots of
papers each box or circle represents
papers or class of papers we don't have
a consensus theory for the origin of
life it's not like it's even worse than
theoretical physics you know your string
theory and all these other theories here
we don't even have a standard model that
people want to attack you just have a
bunch of competing ideas and the only
way to approach the question of the
origin of life on other worlds which is
what I'm supposed to be doing is by
analogy so I've put down all the
theories and say would they work
somewhere else well all of them
suggested for Earth would work for Mars
right so that's that's one reason why
Mars is such a good target some of them
would work for my other favorite worlds
Europa and Enceladus but not all of them
so we're kind of we don't really know
how life got started on earth we're
searching for it for somewhere on
somewhere else many of the theories for
how it got started on earth would work
on the other worlds but not at all so
and some now I'm going to try to start
pushing in the information end of things
and make the distinction between the
physical chemistry of life and the
information content of life so there are
two approaches to the origin of life in
some broad category our first life is a
structure its metabolism first its
reactions first and then I learned to
encode information and reproduce later
so it's chemistry first Hardware first
software later
okay to use the language of computers
the other approach is turns that around
is that first life learned to encode
information and reproduce that
information and then with that knowledge
it built up knowledge on how to build
things on how to eat so this is so this
is eat first think later this is think
first eat later okay well you could say
life started simultaneously thinking and
eating now you've doubled the difficulty
of the problem yeah right so you could
say that somehow you simultaneously
start on both and who knows this is what
the thought is and there's war between
these two camps the metabolism first
versus the replicator first the DNA the
RNA world thinks they solve the problem
in this area they think first there was
the RNA molecule which was able to
reproduce it can do auto catalysis it
can also store information and so it was
the first life and the notion of an RNA
world is very popular now in the origin
of life but then the metabolism people
say that's a bunch of garbage because if
you do any sort of prebiotic synthesis
you can't make RNA world all you can do
is make chemistry you make reactions so
you can make things that are promotable
izing and processing and structures
chemistry is what comes automatically
not information processing so we're at
an impasse but this then I want to just
put a little plug in here for why it's
useful to talk to the IT department
because the language and the mindset of
computer science has really
revolutionized the way we think about
the origin of life and what how life
works and it's given us a vocabulary to
express things much more succinctly and
clearly like stating that life is like a
computer's made up of software and
hardware it's it's a sentence that's
very easy to say now and we all
understand what it means that there's a
component in our body that's hardware
like proteins catalyzing reactions or
the Calvin cycle making energy out of
sugar right that's all hardware
but then there's also information coated
in the genome which is really software
and this distinction was really not even
though the basics was understood it was
not crystallized in the in the field of
the origin life until computer science
developed this
logic and approach to thinking of things
yeah yeah yeah I was looking for
something a little earlier but this is
what I could find right yeah instead of
teasing you of a more serious question
touring compiled his software into
circuits into hardware and ran it there
yeah okay so the two don't necessarily
have to be split this way it's not good
it was a computer all the computing was
in his head right he made a circuit like
the old plug board analog by a writer
field that is no computer was compiled
away you couldn't have any computers
that don't make a distinction between
hardware and software you see of
Babbage's of Computing engines there's
no software hardware it's all in the
wheels right so you can imagine that
that's not the way computers work and
since this paradigm has now been taken
up by biology we've embraced like to see
prints us nobody can make a mechanical
computer that does it they see the
terrain the way yeah and you know this
is an interesting sorry I open up
because when we are searching for life
elsewhere we're assuming the same
software hardware dichotomy that we have
in modern computers and we see in life
on earth right we think there will be a
separation between software and hardware
and this is important practical
implications for how we search and for
example this is a floppy disk one reason
I put floppy disks here is because they
illustrate an essential feature of
information storage is that you don't
want the shape of the storage media to
depend on the information written on it
right you think well it's kind of
trivial and obvious you wouldn't want
the shape of a floppy disk to change if
you wrote a different file on it right
if you think of a protein there's a
molecule that as information in it but
the shape of the molecule depends on the
information in it so you change the
information you change the shape of the
molecule the wonderful thing about DNA
is that it is like a floppy disk you can
change the information content in the
DNA and the physical structure of the
DNA doesn't change that's actually
highly unusual for a chemical molecule
where the the structure doesn't depend
on the information in the molecules that
make it up no DNA is not proteins DNA is
not a protein DNA but I'm making a
general statement that life on another
world where we we are embedded with the
with this paradigm that life is going to
have some kind of molecule that like DNA
can store information without changing
its shape so we have the software
paradigm distinction and it's in our
thinking maybe it's wrong sentence of
this but for instance information can
exist on a light beam that says you can
have a resonant cavity and the modes of
that resident can be contained
information okay and it's possible to
conjecture a form of life in plasma
which is nothing more than the modes of
energy in a residence system yes so so
where as information is central how the
information is encoded that may cloud
our view of what we could see okay I
accept that well you're way beyond what
we're able to do in terms of the search
for life and I'll come to that what it's
possible if you think of this in the
abstract as you're doing sure there's
lots of ways you can encode information
lots of ways you can have physical
systems that
act on that information right the the
point I'm making here is just there's
two points one is the connection
intellectually between the origin of
life and biology now and soft computer
science that's sort of a history of
science point of view poor perspective
the other point is this distinction
between hardware and software which is
real and current computers and real and
current biology as we know it and is the
basis of how we're approaching the
search problem so we'll come back to
that but the the point that this
distinction is a convenience because the
companies that make software are
different than the companies that make
hardware and just a historical accident
it's not a fundamental property I accept
that and I also accept the fact that you
could you could mix them in many
different ways to but this is the way
that we think of we the non computer
people think of computers and this is
the way we think of life now right so
let's go to the hardware for a minute
the the important the important
observation that we're using about the
hardware is that it's what I call Lego
Lego Hardware what I mean by Lego
Hardware is that biology is not just a
random collection of stuff from the CRC
it's certain blocks certain building
blocks stacked in order in long chains
and the complexity comes not from the
diversity of the blocks but from the
combinatorial possibilities of the
stacking this is a fundamental property
of the big giant polymers of biology the
the power and the diversity comes not
from having a large number of of
building blocks but from stacking them
in a large number of ways and that's the
way Legos work right you got a box of
Legos and there's only a few different
types in it but you can build anything
you want out of it in principle by
stacking them in different ways and the
famous the large structure
information containing polymers of
biology are the proteins which are made
out of 20 left-handed amino acids DNA
and RNA made out of nucleotide bases a
handful of them and polysaccharides made
out of sugars those are the Lego blocks
of life on earth and I've argued that
this is likely a common property of
biology as well as mass produced
children's toys throughout the universe
for reasons of efficiency and economy
and select and and select ability this
is likely to be a property Darwinian
evolution will push life toward this
parsimonious utilization of certain
molecules they'll be more efficient than
because each one of these molecules that
you use you've got to control and
produce and stock up and so on
your body's got to process all these
amino acids if you had 100 amino acids
instead of 20 you've got a bigger
problem right so you don't want you
don't want to have to deal with too many
constituents it's a supply chain problem
you don't want to have to amplify your
supply chain problem any more than is
required to get the job done and that's
why this will be a common property
biology everywhere
minimize the supply chain problem and
we're gonna use this principle in the
search for life I'm going to get to this
in steps follow so here is the pictures
of this of these molecules these are the
20 amino acids here are the purines and
pyrimidines and the sugars and added a
few fatty acids and you've got it all
now one of the most amazing results so
far is that we can basically make all
this stuff in the lab for free if you
just take you know famous miller-urey
experiment I didn't have a picture of
the miller-urey experiment so I pulled
one from our lab where we're doing the
same thing and a Titan like experiment
we take nitrogen and methane put it in a
flask put a spark and all sorts of
complex organics are made if you add
water and ammonia you find a lot of
these things are made a lot of things
that aren't these
are made too but these things are made
so you make the building blocks of life
and a bunch of other crap that is not
part of the building blocks of life and
that's the bunch of other crap that's an
important part here what you need to
separate the building blocks of life
from all the other craft is information
right and so the hardware of life comes
for free it's sort of like being able to
create computers by just putting a spark
through a rock silicon rock and have
computer chips fall out right it's that
wonderful that we can do that that
chemistry is that clever that it can do
it that way that life uses so a lot of
these of the 20 amino acids about ten of
them you can get for free by just
running this experiment well this case
was done by Stanley Miller in 1953
Miller Urey did was his PhD thesis where
he did the spark discharge with water
nitrogen ammonia methane water spark and
found that many of the amino acids in
life were produced subsequent to that
about ten years later the discovery of
these same amino acids in the Murchison
and RJ meteorites falling in from space
so they're there in space you make them
in the lab work it's clear that there
we've now discovered them in the
interstellar medium some of the glycine
for example so there you get them for
free you get some of these basic
building blocks for free life just makes
them like I said it's like finding
silicon chips out in the middle of the
desert they're not programmed to blank
but they're there they're very small
percentage of it that maps onto the
biomolecules of life is small I don't
know what it is off the top of my head
but it's small and maybe a percent or
two but so it's mostly black gunk is
mostly tar it's mostly useless from a
biological point of view molecule
but this the stuff that's needed is
there and when Miller that was 70 years
ago now 60 years ago 60 years ago when
Miller publishes result was quite a stir
and the origin of life filled thought
that it was just a matter of a few years
before they'd be able to have life in
the lab they had the same positive
outlook that fusion researchers had back
down this few years just a few years and
they had the same success that the
fusion people have had in producing that
process in the lab but it was a big big
thing because we didn't in retrospect
your eyes this is just the stuff this is
the hardware what's missing is the
software what's missing is the
information required to go from these
bricks of life into a self-replicating
system that stores the information that
assembles the bricks right and I think
we now realize that that's the hard
problem making these chemicals is not a
hard problem that's the easy problem the
fundamental problem is a software
problem not a hardware problem the
universe helps gives you the hardware
problem it's a gift from the from the
periodic table the hardware but where
you get the software we were clueless
yeah so now my interest in this is not
to create life in lab well that'd be
good fun is to use this understanding to
base a search for life elsewhere so my
day job is searching for life okay
that's what reporting to work what are
you here what are you here for
well I supposed to be searching for life
okay you're in cube 3 and so the
attentive the problems were taking I
like this quote I shall not today
attempt to further define it but I know
it when I see it from the Supreme Court
that source of much wisdom is basically
the approach we take to life to when we
go elsewhere we've got example here
we'll know it when we see
and that's the approach I'm taking
you'll see that over again and the
practical implications of that approach
is what is life need don't take try to
define it just try to say what are the
environments on earth which we see that
it survives in and then go look for
those environments a very empirical
theory light observation rich approach
and liquid water is the critical
environment so hence the so called
followed water now the next slide should
have been earlier this is the software
of life this is an example of what I
mean when I say life has software this
is the common words in the language of
all life comparison of this conserved
sequences in the 16s RNA this is data
from James Lake at UCLA and you can see
that in these different organisms from
humans down to Gerardi a-- and corn and
e-coli all have the same sequences in
there in the conserved regions of their
RNA this is almost like there's a tag I
am from Earth I am from Earth I am from
every life-form on earth has the
sequence pay no attention to the viruses
for now that problem is to be solved in
a different seminar but the point is is
that there's all life on Earth runs the
same operating system you can recognize
it just by looking or a metaphor I use
when I'm talking to students is all the
books here are written in English all of
them oh yeah well fungi we're way above
fungi let me see fun gize in here but
this is e coli down here that's a
bacteria right and so here's a pardon up
here Thanks oh yeah fungal cells over
there there's a there's a code here for
in English animals fun design of plants
protozoa archaea all the same and I'll
show soon a tree of life but this is the
software the other thing we know about
life is the sort
a random collection here of things we
know about life is it's a Darwinian
system and this is again traces back to
the information content life is a
material system that shows reproduction
mutation selection based on information
coded in the software manifested in the
hardware and then mutations on the
software you know you could also say
that that you could have a Lamarckian
system where the hardware is the
information and it mutates and it
evolves right there's no Lamarckian
evolution and you may remember is
erroneously attributed to Lamarck by the
angle files who want to privilege
darwinian x' to star ones discovery but
nonetheless we'll take that as labels
Darwinian evolution is there's a
separation between the information and
the instantiation so the hardware is
different from the software the software
programs this hardware then the hardware
interacts with the environment and based
on that there's selection on different
software so that's the Darwinian
paradigm which turns out to be true
there's no way Darwin could have known
that was true you didn't know anything
about DNA but it turns out it is true
there is a separate DNA and a separate
genotype and phenotype and a lot mark
Ian's scheme there is no separation
between the genotype in the phenotype
the in a sense the RNA world is a
Lamarckian world if the molecule changes
its offspring change because it's
information content has changed whereas
in the Darwinian world if something
changes the DNA doesn't change and so
the offspring if you lose your leg your
child is not born without a leg in the
Lamarckian world to lose your leg your
child is born without a leg and the RNA
world is a Lamarckian world and it's not
a lie it's not against the laws of
physics to imagine life forms that are
Lamarckian where the information is what
you were suggesting earlier or somebody
was suggesting earlier where the
hardware
is the software and there they're not
physically separated all right we're not
going to go there because I would never
get a proposal funded that was based on
that right and this will come the so
such a life-form would transcode it's
physical realization as a way of
reproducing it would literally traverse
its physical structure as the recording
of its of its state let me express it
the way I do know which is the RNA world
I should have put up a slide of the RNA
world the RNA world the the RNA molecule
which is like a DNA molecule has
information coated in it but it also
acts directly like a protein in making
catalyzing change so it is both a a
genome and a phenotype so it it
interacts in the environment directly
unlike DNA which is shielded from the
environment our DNA does not interact
with the environment our proteins
interact with the environment right the
DNA instructs us how to build proteins
and the proteins interact with the
environment and then based on that
interaction some DNA's win and some
DNA's lose and those mutations are
selected for that's the Darwin paradigm
and they are the RNA world is not a
Darwinian world
it's a llamar Kian world because the DNA
itself in the RNA sorry itself interacts
with the environment and if there's a
change in that RNA due to some
interaction with the environment if it
loses a nucleotide or gains one then
when it reproduces its daughter
offspring will have that same change
like hardware and the RNA like hardware
plus software know that you maybe you
should because at least for this
community
my help water I think it more in terms
of Darwinian versus remarkable mana I we
don't need to dwell on that too long
because we're gonna ignore the
Lamarckian logic but I put it out there
for completeness you excluded viruses
but you know viruses can read and write
to a DNA like I'm reading writing to a
secret garden by myself at that point
the two are purchasing more similar than
you think
Lucas virus is viruses are I think are
not a very interesting case because they
will not we don't think we'll find them
by themselves ok let's go back on to now
I want to turn to searching for another
example of life a sec what I call second
Genesis as you can see there's a lot of
confusing issues with life understanding
it we don't know its origin what's the
way forward well one way forward has
been sort of try to make it in a
laboratory and this is where computers
come in and computer simulations are
playing a role here and people are
making the RNA world is a group in
Boston and a group in San Diego that are
making the RNA world and trying to
create self-replicating molecules from
the ground up and of course people are
doing biology simulations in the
computer as well same point trying to
understand some of these questions that
we've been talking about as you can see
since I chose a hammer for my icon for
the laboratory I'm not a lab guy so I
don't work in the lab another approach
of course is to wait for them to call
this is SETI you know just wait for them
to call but I'm not very good at waiting
for phone calls so the approach that I'm
involved in and I'm going to talk about
now is go try to find it on another
world so we want more data go find it go
find another example and that we would
learn a lot about these questions by
having more than one example of life so
a lot of the questions might become
reinforced or are answers that we think
are specific to earth light might become
reinforced if we find the same answers
in other life or they might be
proven if we find a different example so
why do we have any idea to think that
there could be a different type of life
and this is a question that biochemists
like to ask me they basically say well
look you know we are right here at the
top of evolutionary selective
optimization anyway you go it's downhill
there can't be another solution now
that's not the words they use but they
basically are saying there's only one
maximum one optimum in the entire phase
space of biochemistry and we're it we're
on that optimum and they're certainly
correct any direction you look from that
optimum is downhill steeply right now
that doesn't prove that there's only one
optimum it proves that we're isolated
that the optimum we're on is isolated
but there may be an optimum way over
here for all we know and biochemistry
the textbook is 500 pages there's got to
be more than one optimum and that many
pages a textbook right that's my
argument
what biochemistry life is a maybe a
localized phenomenon and there may be
several cases where it sticks out now
that doesn't mean that we're looking for
something like silicon life or something
strange this is organic biochemistry and
again I like to express it in terms of
these simple concepts how would that
compare to earth life I'm still
postulating that at the basic level the
life would be composed of carbon and
water not not getting beyond that not to
plasma life or Fred hoes black clouds or
Robert Ford's neutron star life yet love
to see that but one step is just what
can we find in carbon and water so my
argument is that at the bottom it's
going to be the same life is gonna be
carbon in water on Earth like worlds
because carbon and water are the
available resources at the top life is
going to be the same big fish will eat
little fish sunlight will be the energy
source co2 will be the carbon source
ecologically it will be like us and
elementally will be like us we're
there's a possibility for difference is
in the inside it's in the biochemistry
and the information the information
processes which turn this in the systems
that interact like that question I mean
in the conditions that we're accustomed
to is going to be water but with higher
pressure could be co2 or the practical
reason for restricting ourselves to
water because when we look at our solar
system which are the worlds that I can
get to there's only two liquids
accessible in our solar system one is
water and that's on Earth Mars Europa
and Enceladus and the other is liquid
methane ninety-five Kelvin on Titan so
those are the two liquids I care about
you're right theoretically you can
imagine other liquids that are more
suitable than liquid methane that's for
sure
but remember my job is to go out do
missions and search for evidence of life
so it matters what's available to search
for there's no place where we have
liquid co2 there's no place where we
have ammonia which would both be good
candidates for alternative liquids the
only other liquid we have is liquid
methane which is a pretty poor choice
but that's the one I'm focusing on other
than water as I'll say in a second so I
want I'll kind of develop this theme
further and that this information
interior information is what we can hope
to be expect to be different in water
worlds that are still like the earth and
we know how to search for this this is
the Tree of Life we talked about it
already
an alien is an organism not on this tree
this is a little bit of why we would
search for this why are we searching for
a second question here there's a lot of
amino acids form that are not part of
the seventies my life on earth so I was
going to ask about exotic species on see
events events and I see you have extreme
thermal they're not exotic exotic
sense that people who live in Thailand
or exotic they if you for them to them
it's perfectly normal there on our Tree
of Life they use DNA RNA that there
there if you were to grind them up in a
blender they wouldn't look any different
than if you ground up your next-door
neighbors in a blender in terms of the
fundamental 5 caster you know don't do
this experiment at home but the point is
this is all all the same stuff we have
not found anything not on our tree of
life
ok that's the route we if you Transpac
these trees and how you draw the trees
depends on various assumptions and
things it's not a unique mapping but if
you trace it back there's a common
ancestor somewhere around here the last
Universal common ancestor it's why this
is one of the amazing results of biology
over the last 50 years is the tree of
life and the common ancestor and the
relatedness of all life on Earth and
again it's hard to place viruses on this
tree but clearly they're related liquid
or I'm going to speed up a little bit
where to look is the next step Earth
Mars and solidus water as we were
talking about earlier Titan the other
world was a liquid but the liquids not
not water
so the question unfortunately in our
solar system
none of the environments we can access
are likely to be habitable which means
we're not going to likely find anything
that's alive we're gonna find is dead
microorganisms death so we're actually
we're not doing a search for life we're
doing a search for death the distinction
is between something that's dead and
something that was never alive if you're
driving down the road there's a rock on
the ground okay it's a rock and next to
it there's a dead rabbit you know
there's a big difference the rabbit was
once alive and that's what we're
searching for we're not gonna find
anything is alive if something's alive
you can grow it and it can reproduce and
that's how viking tried to search for
life we don't have that option we have
to search for basically dead bodies but
dead bodies are very very interesting
and so another way to phrase that
question is if we find organic material
can we tell if it was ever dead it was
once in a while now so the question is
is what's different about organic matter
that was alive versus organic matter
that was not alive and the poster child
for this difference is the amino acids
in proteins and proteins in life on
earth the proteins contain el
left-handed amino acids in the
meteorites and in the middle URI
experiments we find both left and right
and this gets to your question what was
in the junk
that wasn't biologically useful all the
right-handed protamine Oh acids now a
purist would say well life does use some
of these D amino acids and other things
some of them are poisons and some of
them are used in cell wall linkages but
in proteins it's only the left hand side
left ones right so that's an important
observation life selects chemistry
doesn't this is part of the lingo so of
the Lego principle so express
graphically you can think of a
distribution say you have a clump of
organic matter that came from a
meteorite or from a Miller experiment
you'd expect it to be a a smooth
distribution in some sort of generalized
phase space molecules with similar
properties would have similar
concentrations because they're being
made by chemistry chemistry doesn't care
so simple sócrates means similar
chemistry similar heats of formation
blob will similar degeneracies and so on
biology cares and so molecules with very
similar properties can have vastly
different concentrations the Albee the
concentration of l-alanine is very
different than the concentration of
d-alanine because one is used and
amplified by biology and one is not
write actual conjugate life which is to
say it's energy it's going to be
possible to build a life-form which the
other hand eminence you're dead here
you're at about five slides ahead but
we'll get to that
that thought so this is a distinction
between biology on earth and chemistry
and you can imagine alien life having
the same principle it uses certain
molecules and not others but it uses
different molecules so that's the basic
approach that we want to take in
searching for life now let's refine that
a little bit more and the way to do it I
think is to focus on amino acids there
I'll come back to that as to why there
our focus here but this is a diagram
from a paper we just finished talking
about this problem and pointing out the
distinction between the simple amino
acids and the complex amino acids so
this is a plot of the number of distinct
molecules that are possible as a
function of the increasing complexity of
the amino acids so here at the bottom
where there's one carbon atom there's
only one amino acid glycine and that's
it if you've got a one-cent you here
tell me I've got a one atom one carbon
atom amino acid guess it's name I get it
right every time
glycine but if you were to say I've got
a 10 atom 10 carbon atom amino acid
guess it's name there's like 9 factorial
different versions of it right so I'd be
guessing for a long time right
so the number of possible combinations
goes up very steeply as the number of
carbon atoms goes up that's carbon atom
C number right
these simple ones the C 1 C 2 C 3
there's only 2 or 3 these are also the
ones that are made by prebiotic
chemistry so everybody's going to use
them everybody in the universe that has
amino acid chemistry is going to use
glycine you get it for free it's the
only one of its kind if you've got a C
one amino acid that's it and there it is
and probably same up to C 2 C 3 when you
get to about C 4 or 5 the choices become
astronomical you just can't you have to
pick them so these are the ones that are
used by earth life earth life uses up to
ceefor then a couple c-56 and then a c9
and a c11 right now when you get up to
those large numbers the chance is that
life so the way we think of this is life
inherited these from the prebiotic soup
these simple ones and then it invented
these using evolutionary processes so it
made a selection for these right the
odds that other life would select the
same from the combinatorial diverse set
is vanishingly small and many of them
have the same properties if what life
needed up here was a sulfur rich amino
acid to do stabilization of proteins as
a function of temperature well there's
lots of sulfur rich amino acids so the
chance that it would pick the exact same
one is very very small so our approach
is look for amino acids and look for did
I go backwards no let me go forward this
is I'm going to skip this and go right
now to the amino acid so let's focus on
amino acids
so here's earth let's look at all
possible amino acids of some big set one
interesting thing is life only uses 20
of them and those 20 develop does split
into a 10 that we got for free and a 20
and in the second 10 that we invented
life invented so you can imagine a
strange biology that uses the same 10
but as a different in the second set and
some very important work by Philip and
friedlin showed that alternate sets of
20 can span the phase space of charge
size and hydrophobicity as good as Earth
sets right so they are expressed
mathematically they are as good a basis
vector set for constructing things in
the space as the 20 we have right so
there's well I'll get to that in a
second
in this diagram they're all left-handed
we're just thinking about differences in
the type of amine of type of immuno now
you can also imagine but this is harder
to imagine that doesn't use even the
simple 10 and makes them all stranger
biology has no overlap with earth set
this is what we'd expect overlap in the
simple ones that
in the complicated ones the simple ones
you get them for free and they're unique
the complicated ones you don't get them
for free you've got to make them and
there's a combinatorial vastness and the
number of choices each time you make one
and there is the chirality
there's the handedness so not only does
Earth choose earth not only does life
have to choose the amino acids that it's
going to use it has to choose whether
it's gonna drive on the left side of the
road or the right side of the road once
you've decided then everybody has to
fall in line you go outside all the cars
here are going to be on the right side
of the road we hope right somewhere else
they could all be on the left side of
the road don't go to Italy don't be on
both sides of the room but the as pardon
not necessarily some l-amino acids are
toxic but a lot of medicines now are
made out of sorry D amino acids are
toxic some of the birth defects
associated with ala mine I think we're
due to D amino acid at the time right
right
IVA profane also has some chiral mixin
or as part of its function and now this
is the the industrial sector that's the
most invested in the amino acids is
medicine because they will make
medicines out of the amino acids because
if you're taking a pill it's made out of
al amino acid the protease is in your
saliva and your stomach will tear it
apart whereas if you take a pill made
out of DME no acids those proteases are
ineffective so you can take orally drugs
that would otherwise have to be injected
and they list they last much longer
against the degradation processes in
your body because they're the wrong kind
of amino acids and if you make them with
the same functional shape as their L
Connor parts they have the same efficacy
medically so it's a big industry if
producing D amino acids for medical
application and it will come back to
that in terms of making mirror life
they're the ones that are on the road we
just have to ramp up their technology a
couple orders of magnitude we can make
an entire ecoli that's the mirror image
of itself now if you notice there's a
rabbit over here and not over here and
this is the point in in the original
Alice
well in the original Alice there wasn't
complete symmetry in the two worlds
there was as the physicists would say
there's a parity violation the rabbit
was in one world and not in the other
now we think that there's complete
symmetry here that if you had if you
took an E coli and made its exact mirror
opposite or image all the Al amino acids
become d all the D sugars become L the
DNA Scrolls the other way everything is
the mirror image we think it would
operate perfectly but we have no data to
support that the only data we have on
this is taking this up to the level of
catalysts so they've made groups have
made D catalysts out of D amino acids
and showing that they are specific for D
peptide bonds so that step has been
shown but taking it to the level of the
whole organism we haven't done these
other 10 amino acids to create stranger
biology to incorporate other that and
there are a few natural occurrences of
small instances there's two other amino
acids that are sometimes used in
proteins and sort of in the fringes so
if a purist would say this is really 22
not 20 and people have come up with
other coding schemes besides the coding
schemes that incorporate these that can
incorporate strange amino acids that's
right there's a lot of manipulation in
the we can now manipulate the
transcription process and and very what
I'm suggesting is building the mirror
image of the whole process
josh'll biological hazards of creating
chances of conjugant life this is not
the biological equivalent of ice
you know that Kurt Vonnegut's story ice
9 this would be the bio Idol equivalent
right but you know it's uh I go to this
quote from fine than on his blackboard
what I cannot create I do not understand
we're in that situation with life and we
know that life works we have a solution
the simplest thing that we can make is
the Meerut that's different is a mirror
image of that solution now people you
see in the press they created life well
what they did is they took the genome of
an organism and and then without really
knowing what it does just duplicate it
sort of like taking a Xerox copy of it
then stuffed it into an organism in
which they'd remove the genome and then
boot it up yeah that's impressive and
I'm glad it's a paper in science but
it's not creating life by any stretch of
the definition of the word create right
this would be creating a mirror life
would be great on you would have created
a self-replicating functioning organism
that has no ancestor on earth you've
created a de novo and just enough you're
handed this in the fame that it could
still eat my words can eat both ends of
amino acids they have enzymes rasa mesas
that turn it into the one they like so
you can train microorganisms to to chow
down on D amino acids they turn them in
they raise them to L and use them in
their proteins that's a well-known tool
higher organisms like us we detoxify
them we don't use them we throw them
away but microorganisms who are poor
can't afford to they turn them into L
and but the folium I don't nice tux
yeah so we last thing I talk about is
what are we gonna put these approaches
test my favorite or that I'm Alison
seller's food coming out from
pressurized water pocket full of
organics we want to fly through it take
samples and search for amino acids so if
you say what what is the biomarker we
would search for what is the molecule as
I said the Lego block that we would
search for amino acids are my choice
because we know that they occur
naturally in comets and asteroids we
know that life uses them and we know
that life on Earth has made two choices
in their use choosing the chirality and
choosing the distribution and we know
that at least chirality there's no
reason why life elsewhere couldn't have
made that choice differently there's a
right-left symmetry and we know that in
the distribution we're pretty sure that
10 of the 20 at least are chosen
arbitrarily so we want to explore that
now I want to end with the thought which
is the dog chasing the car right there's
a dog chasing the car and you ask the
dog well what are you gonna do if you
catch the car okay this is an important
question and little kid I get again I
was giving a talk like this not this
talk but a talk to the public at Death
Valley a couple months ago and a
twelve-year-old girl said what are you
gonna do if you find life on Mars all
right you know some people snickered in
the audience but I said that is a
profound question it's the dog chasing
the car problem and generally at NASA we
think nothing about it we don't think at
all about what are we going to do if we
find life on Mars and it is a second
genesis of life that it represents the
first example of a life form that is not
on our tree of life what are we going to
do well I think this brings up the
question which I'm not going to dwell on
but the moral status of alien
microorganisms if we find the second
Genesis in our solar system I contend
that then there are three sets that
warrant moral consideration humans of
course or a set that warrant moral
consideration life itself is a set that
warrants more
consideration not equal to everyone in
the set but we all appreciate there's
something special about life in the case
of humans we not only appreciate there's
something special but we want to assign
sort of an equality within that set we
don't do that in life but that doesn't
detract from our sense of its
specialness now we find another example
of life that's a new set life - so I
would argue that microbes which score
low moral status based on any of the
criteria that are assigned for moral
status feeling pain complex behavior
communication cuddly little smiles
whatever it is that you like about life
that gives makes you have the moral
regard for it are low on bacteria and in
fact you probably kill thousands of them
when you wash your hands and brush your
teeth and I encourage you to continue
doing that but what if we found them on
Mars they would have high moral status
as being the sole representatives of the
set life 2.0 that's it it's the last
Buffalo taken to the microscopic level
level and the diversity taken to the
highest possible level a completely
different type of light so what does
this mean like say this is just silly
philosophical ramblings but it's not I
actually argue that it has immediate
implications on how we explore these
worlds and the conclusion which I won't
dwell on but I developed in a couple
papers is the robotic and human
exploration of Mars should be done in a
way that is biologically reversible we
must be able to undo again the computer
metaphors entering into our language my
favorite one is the undo ctrl Z I think
it's a wonderful concept to you know
imagine I would like to have that in my
life you know controls eConsult let's
control Z the whole day everybody right
aren't there times when that would just
be the thing to do so far we have
contaminated Mars but our contamination
is reversible we can control Z an
example of irreversible contamination is
the rabbits in Australia you can undo
that
but if the two rabbits that had started
the Australia colony had been dropped
off in Antarctica instead of Australia
you could undo that contamination you
just go back and find him two dead
rabbits not far where you left them
right so everything we've done on Mars
so far is undo it as we can reverse it
and if we discover a second genesis of
life there we should hit the undo button
until we've cleaned it up by going to
our landing sites after biting when we
stopped sterilizing spacecraft and
collecting all the hardware and bringing
it back to earth or sterilizing it
rigorously in place we stopped
sterilizing spacecraft after Viking and
so curiosity which just landed on Mars
year before last carried with it
500,000 viable microorganisms from Earth
that was its bioburden allowable by
Oberg
it sounds like a lot but you know the
dishes in my apartment are to have more
bacteria per square centimeter than that
on and so it's not clean and out it's
clean it's not sterile
most of those microorganisms would be
killed upon exposure to the Martian
environment UV but the ones inside the
spacecraft shielded by metal or plastic
will only be killed over timescales of
thousands of years by cosmic rays so we
can ask to me now that there's about two
or three million Earthlings on Mars
dormant inside various spacecraft we
know where they are we know where all
the pieces are there in the litter that
we put on the surface and as long as
they're inside and as long as Mars is
dry and cold they're not growing they're
not doing anything if we wait long
enough they will die but that's
thousands and thousands of years so if
we find a Mars as light and that it is
the second Genesis there is a conflict
there between our contamination and that
life but so far we can understand the
Mars that one still that's why our
pictures there kitties remain on the
surface they are living in a biocidal
bath of UV radiation so the only things
that aren't killed instantly are things
that are inside plastic or metal and so
as long as we
keep track of all the bits of plastic
and metal so that we can pull them up if
we have to we can do its own principle a
human base is reversible as well now if
you were to say drill deeply down into
an aquifer and contaminate that that's
not reversible right the surface of Mars
is doing us a favor being incredibly
inhospitable and being bathed by UV
light down to 190 nanometers which is
very biocidal you would biologists would
love to have that kind of sterilizing
capability in their cleanroom I question
here this flyby mission to one of the
moons - are you expecting to carry
laboratory equipment of all allow you to
do full molecular characterization
aspects and they are sequencing and we
like that but what I'm and what's there
now is able to do this what's on what's
on Cassini it's flown through the plume
is a mass spec that goes up to a hundred
amu and has a resolution of one mass
unit it's sort of like a $3,000 RG a
residual gas analyzer that might be in a
plasma physics lab that's great but it's
not well one state-of-the-art GCMs we'd
be able to get that that's why I'm
focusing on what single molecule do I
want to focus on amino acids so focus
the analytical capability on that I'd be
great to be able to characterize all
large molecules all natural molecules
you know as you could do with the sample
return to earth which is what we really
want to do but in since you I would just
focus on the amino acids you just
measure that and then maybe would only
pick a few of them a few of the 10 and a
few of the 20 you don't go through the
whole set of all possible amino acids
it's too hard but you might look at
glycine it's almost certainly going to
be there and then you might look at say
alanine and Sarah and see are they both
of the same chirality on earth life
the alanine and the sarin the two simple
chiral ones would both be el dominated
by el that would be pretty cool if they
were both dominated by al on Enceladus
it'd be even cooler if they're both
dominated by deep alright then you might
look for
complex sulfur-containing amino acids to
see if life had invented something out
there at high carbon number and that if
we could do that I'd I would die a happy
man that's enough not so much function
of bigger is cost more right now we're
aiming for a discovery target which
means we're restricted to small
instruments one and two and we're
competing with people who want to do
other things that aren't related to the
search for life like go look at rocks or
sulfur volcanoes on Io and so on so we
have to have a solid science story and
it has to be cost effective so we can't
we can't we can't get there on the first
step now if we fly through and find
amino acids and there's a higher
concentration of D then we can write our
own check for the next mission
right so it's a step at a time question
here like this isn't it more possible
for finding a second Genesis on
Enceladus or the exchange of material
between Mars and Earth yes that was a
very good point and that's this air out
here which is increased chance of life
not related to earth life so there may
be life on Mars and as you're suggesting
it may turn out to be us carried their
maps on our Tree of Life and the further
we get from Earth more likely what we
find if we find anything is that it's
alien of course since Titan
wins on that hands down because we're
not related to anything that lives in
liquid methane not by any launch any
chance at all right but these other
worlds are water worlds so it's possible
that life from Earth contaminated these
worlds or vice-versa
or they all shared contamination from
somewhere else so it may be that we'll
find life here here and here and then
we'll map right on our tree of lights it
will not be a second Genesis well we
looking for optically active stuff yeah
that's what I don't want to do on this
mission is look for we don't call it
optically active anymore
that's a historical term from how it was
first discovered chirality left and
right was discovered by Louis Pasteur
because of the rotation of light and so
he's been called optically but that in
the biochemical world that terminology
is sort of considered quaint and
old-fashioned now we just call it
different we call chirality so we will
definitely want to tech detect chirality
and look at the difference because and
the all amino acids that life uses
except one have these two chirality
glycine is too simple so it doesn't have
chirality but alanine and serene for
example very simple amino acid still but
they have chirality so those would be
ones we would definitely look for and
see if one chirality dominates over
another and the meteorites they're about
the same to ask the question the
old-fashioned way
the places you might be able to remote
detection sharing my own detection of
chirality from the interaction from the
scattering of the microwaves and to me
that was a Tiffany the tough part how
far wealth of the signal isn't very far
problem to me that was I suddenly now
had a suddenly blinding flash of light
it was my road to Damascus moment that
is how the tricorder works right so all
these years I've wondered how did the
tricorder work so here's here's Spock in
orbit and he's detecting life on a
planet below you say well what is the
property of life that they're detecting
so they can differentiate it from
non-biological matter what is the
property of life that could be detected
remotely and the property is its kyra
life is chiral it selects only kind of
I forget what you need but whatever you
need it's just a matter of the engineers
to work it out now yeah I've got the
paper on my computer I could pull it up
yeah just tactical difficult the
conceptual solution is now in hand we
have that solution to how a tricorder
understand that when you say chirality
and its optical significance is the
absorption spectra of circularly
polarized light is different there's a
whole additional diversity to the
absorption spectra based upon circularly
yes can't be seen with single but this
is not you just develop molecules
they're a quartz calcite crystals will
do the same thing they they transmit
okay yeah but anyway yeah that's the
same thing you can that's what they do
that's the that's the correct answer
that's the non-biological akuel
birefringence crystalline is basically
having two frequencies but it's K Omega
if you assume that Enceladus doesn't
currently have life but but did and it's
been dead for a billion years at
ordinary temperatures which we assume it
has to be because we have liquid water
natural rhythm ization occurs right at
what point do you lose the ability to
discriminate that it was once yeah an
animal yeah that's a good question
very indeed this is a long time than
zero degrees the good thing about Mars
is it it's been frozen it's deep
sediments have been frozen and minus 60
which is much better than zero for
preservation so I would not be
optimistic about finding stuff on
Enceladus because zero is not a very
good storage temperature Mars and the
permafrost the deep permafrost I would
be because minus sixty would get you to
the age of the solar system so if it's
dead a long time but the good thing
about Enceladus is the samples are fresh
they're coming out of the water right
now so I'm hoping it's only been dead a
few hours those last days over time
that's been measured and the fact is
used as an aged ad on teeth and things
like that why can't you have a
coexistence of both handedness of life
and the same ecosphere
why can't we all just get along systems
where an equilibrium could exist this
would be an interesting question for
computer simulations if you can do an
adequate simulation are there solutions
where you can have two systems that
compete at the fundamental level
so what are they to people or they can't
eat each other but they compete for
access to sunlight access to water and
access to physical space actually Chris
if you would come to dinner
you could ask them the woman who can
answer that question it's coming to
dinner oh and when you're fortunately
Gina what's the regular dinner the
telecom Japan is so many powers
different this is a rigorous Japan
mission we have a telephone at 6:00 to
start designing the sample return
capsule and so I'm gonna have to miss
dinner but your point is that people are
giving these computer simulations and
that's one one of the things I'm saying
we could learn we can do things in the
computer that we can't do in the real
world yet eventually we'll be able to
make mirror life and we'll put ecoli
left and e.coli right in the same box
hopefully Kirk tightly sealed and see if
they could coexist
my my conclusion is sources are to
Genesis's
that's much harder to the other well I
would actually think that what happened
is we have all the world the second from
the first well here the cross Genesis
you have a a process by which you
transform one into the other in the
story in a story I have multiple Genesis
we think it's easy it started many times
but life is a winner-take-all game that
at one point somebody eats everybody
else out of the game and I think that
will show up in the computer simulations
that if you do the simulations correct
to nature you will not have two systems
one will eventually out eat the other
and drive it so blessed handedness in
biology sort more like ninety percent
it's not a hundred percent precinct no
in the sense I don't mean that but I
mean we are all part of the same yes
some true but if you analyze the brain
of a hand for the handedness by ninety
percent is today okay that's that's a
different thing I'm talking about the
question was could you imagine more than
one tree of life let's generalize it not
just to R&D amino acids but go back to
this tree why is it not the case that on
earth why is it the case on earth all
life is related
why couldn't you imagine that we see on
earth two separate biospheres biological
systems that represent trace back to
separate distinct origins in the same
sense that we have English and Chinese
they are both written in paper they both
in books and they both compile human
knowledge but there's a fundamental
difference in the logic of the way they
encode information in in this world all
the books are in English there are no
books in Chinese and so the question not
I'm generalizing your question why
couldn't you imagine that on earth you
had a second genesis of life growing
over here and our genesis here happily
sharing the earth plenty of you
system space for all we don't see that
my argument would be that at one time
there probably was and it's just a
matter of competition and eventually one
type dominates and excludes the other
out of all niches and drives it to
extinction
it's a winner-take-all game and I bet if
you do the simulation right you find
that in the computer simulations Chinese
what I'm saying is is P we put these two
species which cross translates the
ecosphere you could get systems but
again these are all questions that could
be addressed in simulations we can't
address them in nature because we can't
make we can't even reproduce this much
let's make an alien one to compare it to
mere life would be the first example of
us trying to do that create a mirror
life and compare it so I'm all for this
line of inquiry I think it's a
fascinating question to me it would be
highly surprising if life started off
this way and just developed this way I
think almost certainly at some point
there was more diversity at the whole
life level and then it got window down I
mean there's kind of a weak parallel to
this in homo sapiens and at one point
there are multiple species of humans now
there's only one you could take the view
that it's a winner-take-all game there
too so you know I think much as we might
think
share and share alike is a good moral
philosophy it may not apply to nature in
the raw the detection of chirality how
would you translate that into a remote
sensing problem well obviously you're
saying earlier maybe their methods
the planets for example because you tell
the difference between these times
remotely one one technique that's on the
gist developing is Raman spectroscopy
and the other is this radio frequency
wave basically looking at well if you
can fly up to it you can get pretty
close to Enceladus now
I don't know I'm acting with all the
docs I use I don't know how far the
tricorders range was it certainly worked
from orbit so against Soviet Soviet
missiles so ya go pretty far is a piece
of technology feasibility and
application but now you need to play my
kids I mean they have exquisite hardware
but they're very buggy software yeah in
fact you're that moral equation already
distinguish between human and micro but
kind of are crayons dan and humans were
probably a pretty significant percentage
made up of microbes yes
so has kind of couple things come out of
that if we discover microbes someplace
else
l2 microbes might we assume we have to
assume there's a higher-level
ordering wait until we can just freak
out Travel equation the second question
is is there a way by looking at microbes
detect whether there is higher than one
associated with them let's go
question the first I've thought about
the second I haven't so if you go back
to the tree of life let's see it's in
here
here it is these are my coordinates was
the blue the red and the blue trees they
are both inside of us the archaea and
bacteria live inside it's mostly
bacteria but the archaea do as well one
of the curious features is that only
these branch the red branch causes
infection so only the red stage the
dangerous the blue states or not no now
for for most of us history there was no
multicellular organism it was only these
guys so they could certainly imagine an
eco sphere an ecosystem with only my
cord your other question is more
interesting is there any if you had
samples from here and here could you
know that this existed I don't think so
because if you could do it the other way
around if you had these guys you would
know that these guys existed because
these guys have all the these guys are
have metabolic diversity up here the
diversity to oversimplify is only
morphological these are all the same
they're just they're all aerobic they're
all eukaryotes tac-2 just look different
but here they now they don't look
different they all look the same roughly
speaking but they they have different
chemistry's some like oxygen some don't
some you sulfur some use iron so there's
all the metabolic diversity and the
biosphere is in these two branches so
looking at these guys you could see that
they must have had ancestors or cousins
are related that had more diversity than
they do but looking at these two I don't
think you can infer that one I'll think
more about it but I haven't thought
about it before but just thinking about
it now on the spot I don't think so
Wow four times you know I got it
middle-of-nowhere give it talking oh
you're from NASA don't you guys have
aliens hidden in your secret storage
locker and I say yes indeed and I'm
happy to show you a picture of them
there they are these organisms are
definitely not on our tree of light and
that is our definition of alien so this
might be more serious that I'm back to
the viruses they are left and right can
the torus ugly some of them are so this
may put the real spin on your story yeah
but not in the amino acids remember the
DNA is there the Khairallah chirality
becomes a little mushy and it's not even
clear the chirality is important to DNA
because you unzip it before you do
anything with it
yes but the amino acids that's another
reason why I like amino acids because
they're the chirality is clear so can't
mix it good song you know me the virus
is meiosis can do something they can not
maybe I might rewrite DNA and then when
they when they're controlling they make
proteins they're still right made out of
left-handed amino acids so that's much
more Universal in biology than the
chirality and DNA and the chirality and
sugars is interesting but not as
important as in protein so that's why we
focus on amino acids and proteins and as
the key molecule it's one of the
arguments why the one biomarker I want
to search for when we get to these other
worlds is amino acids and this signature
because and I think that's yeah this
this this is it amino acids are the
aren't for a lot of reasons are the best
molecule search for first now once you
find them DNA is a lot more interesting
than amino acids but if you're doing the
first search if we find amino acids and
we find a signature like I said we'll
then get the money to do the real
mission where we send a big lab up there
tossed out the buyer story so I hope you
have two words I don't want to sidetrack
you all right
okay I'm here this afternoon so just
thanks for your attention
you